this is a production of cornell
university
good afternoon everyone and it really is
a pleasure to see you here this
afternoon i have some formal remarks but
i've decided that it's too beautiful a
day to stick to a script so i hope
you're okay with my taking some
a little bit of freedom here to talk
about this wonderful project that we're
about to see unfurl uh this afternoon
and the importance of the concept of
being rooted and and and how important
that concept is not only to our faculty
and our staff but certainly to our
students that they feel that they have a
home here
at cornell and that they feel that all
that has led them to come to be here at
cornell is part of being rooted rooted
in who they are and who they're going to
be and that cornell plays an important
role in that process of becoming who you
are and who you are going to be i just
would like to thank justin conrad whose
wonderful genius it was to to create uh
who have contributed to the the
unfurling of this beautiful exhibit here
today and now i'd like to turn the
microphone over to marvin fritz chairman
of horticulture to say a few words so
mark
thank you
so here we stand at the intersection of
art and science
a symbolic junction of apprehension and
perseverance
where we display to the world a part of
our collective character that many words
cannot easily express
but which one word reveals
before we contemplate the planning
before us
let us take a moment to appreciate the
rich fertile soil that we have in this
place
not the literal soil under our feet but
the metaphorical soil that is cornell
university in the surrounding area
soil is composed of minerals organic
matter microorganisms and water
the mineral elements of our metaphorical
soil are the geological features of this
region with its hills lakes gorges and
waterfalls that surround us
the lush vegetation and the bountiful
fruit vegetables dairy and wildlife that
we find here comprise the organic matter
the soil's moisture represents a sweat
of our forbearers who risk life and
limbs
sustain themselves in this place
and build an institution that is the
envy of the world
no living soil is complete without its
biological component
our living cornell soil contains
thousands of faculty and staff who care
deeply about the success of students and
work hard to make this place
special there is no better soil than
sustainable community anywhere else in
the world
it is into this soil that we invite each
of you to establish your roots
sink them deeply into the medium that is
provided to you for the taking
drink the moisture that is contained in
the soil suck up the nutrients and grow
and develop into a beautiful flower that
brightens the world and brings joy and
pleasure to others
like these flowers
each of us have different colors
black white brown
christian jewish muslim buddhists
gay and straight young and old rich and
poor
and just as this display will be all the
more beautiful from its diversity of
colors and shapes
so to this place will be richer from
those of us who dare seek our roots into
a soil that we call cornell
as we move through the coming weeks of
exams
and possibly graduation
look upon rooted with the knowledge that
whatever comes our way we will not
simply cope but we will blossom
we are strong we are rooted we are
um i just wanted to thank everyone for
coming today it's a great
day
and
when i started working with marcia this
fall
we're thinking about something that we
could do that would involve the whole
campus community
really
really mean the word of inclusiveness
and really bring collaborations we have
so many vast resources at cornell and
thinking and
this is
a child and
i am so thankful
are um to continue our roots
so thanks everybody for coming um it
occurs to me we didn't introduce people
to you we had our dean of state board
i'm vicki first
department of horticulture chair marvin
justin kondrat who's the brains behind
this operation a graduating senior
uh spoke next and i'm marcia iam sheegly
i do just want to say a few words of
thanks but first i want to point out if
you're not aware of it there are solar
lights woven through the insulation so
that you'll be able to enjoy it at night
and in the day it'll be colors of pale
white and yellow and at night it'll be
red and white
just a few people to thank from the
beginning we've had so many people
involved with this bill miller provided
bulb expertise we had people that range
from the lgbtq community to the
department of horticulture planting the
13 000 bulbs um justin was the the one
who was the creative influence who got
so excited and started talking about the
clock tower and i really didn't believe
that that could happen i feel like it's
sacred turf i can't believe they let us
do this and we're really grateful we had
the grounds department and gannett
health services involved
um i always want to make sure that we
thank the people who
capture this forever craig cramer jason
koski are taking images that will allow
us to enjoy this for always and not just
for the two weeks that the installation
will be in place
and lastly i think i've acknowledged
everyone else i really want to say i
mean this seriously this could only
happen at this university
i think that other places wouldn't
recognize the value of public art as a
means to inspire and inform not just to
be pretty but to have a message and to
carry a message to the world and it's an
important one and we're so grateful that
our administration
sees this as an important gesture and
not just a pretty one
without their support we certainly
wouldn't have the opportunity to play
and express ourselves in this particular
way it's always tricky when you start
thanking people there's the danger of
leaving someone out i think i am
mentioned everywhere there have been a
lot of people involved so we thank you
for coming we hope you enjoy it the
grounds crew the grounds department um
the grounds department and the
greenhouse staff
helped us out a lot too so thanks
everybody we hope you enjoy it as it
continues to change over the cup next
couple of weeks
we know that it will burn in that means
that the pots will exclude the light and
when we pull them up in two weeks you'll
still be able to see the pattern and
that'll be interesting so thanks for
coming out and we hope you enjoy it
we have our formal ribbon settings
there you go
okay
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu
you